depuis deux siècles le théâtre s'affiche
sur les murs de la province
ABA NQ on les conserve précieusement
comme un trésor d'information sur notre
histoire théâtrale c'est une mosaïque
photographique comme on l'appelle donc
avec des portraits en mosaïque des
membres d'une compagnie amateur une
troupe amateur de Montréal l'association
dramatique de Montréal
et tout en haut on a les en fait les
figures
protectrices de la troupe d'amateurs qui
sont en fait des grands noms du théâtre
de cette époque là qu'on est vraiment à
l'époque où le théâtre francophone
bascule
d'un mode amateur vers un mode
professionnel et le monde de la fiche de
théâtre a aussi ses stars des
illustrateurs comme Vittorio ou Yvan
Adam des créateurs aussi prolifiques
qu'inspirés c'est une affiche souvent
qui va ruser avec les codes
publicitaires pour pour inviter le
spectateur au théâtre et c'est un type
d'affiche qui est particulièrement
intéressant
l'objectif capter l'attention du passant
et le transformer en spectateur ils
affichent les plus percutantes elle va
pouvoir aller dans des domaines où on
est plus dans l'atmosphère d'une pièce
où on est davantage dans l'univers de
création du metteur en scène où la fiche
peut même devenir une prolongement de ce
qui est présenté sur scène donc vraiment
un objet artistique à part entière dans
certains cas la collection patrimoniale
d'affiches de bibliothèques et archives
nationales compte près de 5000 affiches
et la plus ancienne remonte après de 200
ans c'est une affiche programme c'est
vraiment un document un peu hybride qui
date de 1825 qui date de l'ouverture du
premier théâtre royal à Montréal un
théâtre qui était dans ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui le vieux Montréal sur le
site du marché Bon Secours la moitié des
affiches ont été numérisés ils sont
disponibles sur le site de bamq et les
visiteurs peuvent y voir en vrai ce
rendez-vous à la Bibliothèque nationale
c'est Rosemont il signait bien Alexandre
Chartier Radio-Canada Montréal